hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm childish Humphrey no we are
going to watch a TV spot for the Lion
King tickets now on sale I'm going at
comic-con
we are going to comic-con that week so
hopefully we get to go to a Disney press
screening I'm getting a positive review
out there Disney shills over here they
own all of us when you really think
about it anyhow let's watch this
most likely non-monetized video because
it's a song but I want to check it out
for that love Beyonce lemonade go listen
to that album if you haven't heard
already what are you doing with your
life look at the Stars
[Music]
those kings will always be up there to
guide you
[Music]
Oh and so will I this house The Lion
King rated PG tickets on sale tomorrow
like dart piano touching the amp that's
gonna be the next trailer is gonna have
a slow dark cover of can you feel the
love tonight it sort of feels like we're
headed down that path I mean I thought
it was nice that they led with just like
a harmony and not much instrumentation
because for as much of a debate as
they're inevitably always is with every
musical movie about the you know singing
voices versus the performance voices on
that stuff I do get the creepiness
because most of this takes place at
night and they're looking up with the
stars but I thought this was a much
better approach than like taking a
snippet out of Prince Ali was for
Aladdin yeah well I guess my one thing
with this specific TV spot is why was it
more you know Simba and Nala focused
yeah well again you'd be able to love
deny the debuting their song is it about
some did they really change the
relationship between Mufasa and Simba
here they're gonna subvert expectations
and properly abusive this is gonna be a
mandala is it gonna link to the times
that we're living in dominantly I think
the kids who are watching this reaction
know exactly what i'm referring yeah
yeah they're always getting to the sorry
kids uh pissed to day 'test
political affairs you know light enough
for the adults and older teens
understand what I'm saying yeah yeah but
just enough where a kid has to ask their
parent why what are they talking about
why did Papa Greg say that that's what
the little kids call me aunt uncle Greg
s is better yeah that's great that's
creepy Papa break whenever a little kid
recognizes me I always say call me uncle
kids recognize I'm trying to think of
what the youngest person is only running
as little kids with disabilities which I
believe is the main demographic
this channel we have contributed heavily
to this review of the TV spot I do think
it is kooky in a little a little bit at
least that yeah this is focused in on
Simba and Mufasa and Nala doesn't show
up like at all
yeah there's trailers so it's an odd
pairing for sure well you know where I
cannot feel the love tonight it's coming
from a man named Jay and Valente painted
on the day shout out to this guy Jay an
my dude you have been are one of our top
reward to your pledges for a long long
long time past two months almost three
now haven't heard back from you dude
nothing where's the love money can't buy
us love it buys us clothes to love it's
usually the door that opens into love
for us so you're there you've opened the
door with your pledge but now we need
the emotional support I mean first the
support it's definitely the financial
part that's gotta make a living easy way
to our heart but dude I need to hear
back from you soon I need one of your
crazy random stream-of-consciousness
possibly alcoholic induced messages to
get back to us as soon as possible yeah
please it's always easy to reply to you
yeah I look for one sentence out of a
whole monologue and I just go with that
you know I forget just can't wait to be
king just can't wait to hear back from
Jay and velentin it's the song I'm gonna
be singing on the way to the theatres
with this well I'm glad a lot of people
asked us to cover this video yeah plenty
of new footage in here oh I see what
they're doing different with can you
feel the love tonight and this may be
invert expectations this is gonna be all
about fatherly love and like parental
love you know like family love and
there's gonna be no romantic subplot
whatsoever and Simba is gonna be by it's
gonna be great I'm excited
well guys you can subscribe to the react
nation hit that like button
notification bell